Tom Porter is southern region chief for
Cal Fire the state's largest fire
department Cal Fire's managing the major
fires in Southern California right now
chief Porter good morning to you good
morning Jeff what are your biggest
concerns right now biggest concerns
right now are with the fire the Thomas
fire out in Ventura County
oh hi the town of Ojai is threatened by
fire now having a lot of trouble with
the winds and the fire activity there
the peak winds are one of the worst
times that you're worried about worst
times it really was from about midnight
this this evening through all of today
into tonight and then as we get into
Friday things will start to subside a
little bit but continued bad wind you do
this color-coded chart and you've never
had purple on it before explain what
that is that's correct we have this
Santa Ana Wildfire threat index and
today is the first time a purple rating
has shown up that's the most extreme
rating that we have and it indicates
that any spark can and will start a fire
and fires that start will be almost
impossible to contain almost impossible
to kill most impossible you're bringing
folks in from where and talk about the
numbers of firefighters involved at this
point yeah actively on the fire line
right now we have about 5,000
firefighters fighting all three of these
blazes and then we have several thousand
additional that we're moving into the
Southern California area those that are
already here in the fire departments are
part of that we also have fire fighters
coming from as far as Colorado Oregon
and the western states to help with this
people really need to be ready to go as
I mentioned with the extreme conditions
of the purple days we aren't going to be
able to contain these fires people need
to get out of the way it's it's saving
lives so when we have this kind of these
kind of conditions chief thanks very
much for your time Jeff back to you in
New York
Jeff and those images from the freeway
are just incredible our thoughts to the
victims out there